hot breath like i always ask comics like
a story of getting
booed on stage or just like the most
epic
bomb they've had in their career which
what stands out to you
well you know usually it's funny usually
people who boo now it's usually one boo
and it's usually
you said something they didn't like it's
like go [__] yourself
[__] child oh you didn't hear you got
offended
it's like you just laughed at five
minutes of [__] me making fun of this
guy's face
you're fine with that i'm sure he wasn't
i'm sure deep down
somewhere he was like this hurts you
know what i mean but he was laughing at
it
but you know you don't really get booed
anymore
there's got to be some bombs you've had
i've had bombs but
i mean i deserve them you know shouldn't
have been there
you know outdoor [__] yeah
um i don't really bomb anymore i do good
oh yeah this is like in the early days
when you're like still trying to figure
it out
yeah i mean i've bombed i mean the worst
most
i mean i don't mind i've had big bombs
but
the most terrifying bomb i had was
in in buffalo outside of buffalo i did
an all-black
underground nightclub yes and
i don't i was you know i did i did black
rooms all the time in new york and i
love
just all black crowds yeah i do yeah i
do i'm in atlanta all the time
because if you're funny you're funny
exactly they do not want to laugh they
want to laugh but if you stink you'll
know about it
yep but if you're funny there's no
better and
it doesn't matter what you say if it's
funny they'll laugh
[Music]
um and i remember i just was so cocky i
i took the train up there and i remember
the guy that picked me up was a
legitimate
pimp like he was a pimp he had a big
medallion and he gave me a big
bucket of chicken wings and i was like
i was just sitting in the car with like
30 wings in a bucket
in this big suv and uh uh he's like yeah
most comics
we get they love those and i was like
okay
i think i don't i really want wings
right now you know
and uh he dropped me off the hotel and
there's i mean this other guy knocked on
the door big [__] he came in
i'm here to pay you and he counted out
the cash
2500 bucks cash on the bed he goes count
it i go i trust you goes count it
i was like okay okay and one two and i
remember i did this gig and the kid that
went up before me
was a local emcee he hated it that i was
there
he was like you're using this [__]
piece of [__] and you're not headlining
me
and he was mad he went up buried me i
went up and
bombed i mean and this guy from the back
said something and i started trashing
him and i was getting laughs
so i said i look at you [__] you
[__] toothpick [__] with a [__]
wife beat her on
go [__] is and he charged the stage they
had to grab him
he was literally a murderer he was like
a killer and a gang
and i just was [__] with him so then
i just walked off
then they had the kid went back up he
goes i told you this [__] they
bring these [__] up [__] that
they started trashing me they were dying
laughing and this big guy walked up and
he goes yo you got to go up
you defend yourself you go to battle
like like it was like eminem
right you know like i was a rabbit i was
like no i'm good he goes
no you have no choice you've got to go
defend yours and he handed me a mic and
as i'm walking up
this kid was trashing me he's like nah
man you can do this to me [__]
it was a nightmare so then all i stopped
i
sat over in this room and the guy walked
up he goes yeah i'll be with you in a
minute
he was mad he was mad that he paid me
all this money
and i'm sitting there for two and a half
hours it turned into a nightclub
so two and a half hours i'm just sitting
in this little corner
finally i just went to this woman who
was dating this guy or whatever and i
said
could i go please and she was like oh
baby all right
this guy walked over and he goes yo drew
this kid to it like a 14 year old kid
his little cousin
goes drive this [__] home so
this little kid drove me home in this
big
i don't care i don't care that we get
pulled over
i know you don't have a license he got
me back to hotel i got my money i went
to the train station
i hid between a a soda machine and a
vending machine until the train came
at like 6 30 in the morning oh and i
just fi i got
out of there it was [__] terrifying
2500 cash
2500 cash in my sock oh my waiting for
somebody to just
i was just waiting for a couple cars to
pull up yo
we're gonna need that money back i was
like alright here you go yeah
see you later i spent 20 on a coke
and a bag of nachos yeah dude it was bad
how how long into your career was that
geez man that had to be the early that
would be the late
two late night 1998 99
maybe 2000 something around there you
know it was it was
it was i was cocky enough to think i
could do anything and it really brought
me back down to earth